[Musique]
dans ce lieu unique j'ai constitué une
team d'experts top niveau
vétérinaire toiletteur
comportementaliste éducateurs aucun
animal ne leur fait peur ils ont un
objectif et un seul voler au secours des
maîtres les plus désespérés je suis
célibataire depuis trois ans à cause de
lui
c'est le fils de lucifer en fait non
bancaires
ce sera une vraie révélation c'est
incroyable c'est génial vivre en
harmonie avec votre animal de compagnie
et bien c'est notre mission à l'animal
académique
[Musique]
ici on est libre ou lait allégé daniel
moreau veut dire que ça me fait de la
peine parce que christophe dechavanne
s'est quand même l'animateur le plus
talentueux de sa génération
et voilà il est le voir faire ça et je
pense que c'est juste un problème
d'attitude de comportement il est
ingérable tf1 n'en veut plus d'eux veut
plus en entendre parler
il a eu une chance cet été avec je suis
une célébrité on a été une carte une
personne ont paraît-il
non mais en tout cas une chance
d'admirer le problème déjà oui mais
enfin quand même c'était un trajet
mandela c'est un chien tegra est vrai
mais jeune c'était un des premiers à
remettre les magiciens peu en route et
en scène war est à l'époque de coucou
c'est oui à pas bien sûr c'est lui y
avait bernard bilis un appartement grand
miles inquiet du closer c'est vrai que
cet animateur je l'adoré c'est qu'est ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui aucune chaîne de
télé mise à part tes fans ne veulent
reprendre pendant ses huit ans alors
écouté et on est déjà très long botté et
zach déjà que faut jouer des coudes en
plein désarroi je crois je connais moi
je suis pas dans ceux connus mais j'ai
l'impression et nicolas pourra peut-être
de confirmer que christophe il a un
caractère particulier
là je suis j'ai un peu c'est un bateau
c'est pour moi alors je sais qu un
génocide
allez-y tube tu peux rouler leurs volets
stores dechavanne c'est tout et les gens
donc le vitrail et green tous en fait
j'ai développé je vous en prie vous
pouvez rien me dire vous pouvez rien
vous pouvez rien partager avec lui vous
pouvez pas lui demander de faire ça et
non ça voilà donc il en train de glisser
doucement mais y en a d'autres hélas
dans ce métier mais sabrina qui quittent
pas jacques martin était quelqu'un de
très dur c'est pas les limites c'est
léon zitrone et patrick savatier que
j'ai remis à l'antenne sur france
télévisions c'est quelqu'un qui n'est
pas toujours simple à gérer voilà même
si ça marche ça vous embête qui sont
ingérables
parce que christophe dechavanne à
l'époque c'était un moment donné vous
défendre les patrons de chaînes le mec
si les ingérables et qui fait des scores
de ouf on est à kaka sur la tête brûlée
question de caractère ont connu elles
quand même fils est effectivement sortez
moi de là mais aussi de wall en access
force est de constater que le succès n'a
pas forcément été au rendez vous alors
kevin vatant qui lui est sérieux et
surtout ils avancent très souvent dans
les interviews que c'est un problème
d'âge sont bien appliquées christophe
dechavanne à 60 61 ans jean luc
reichmann en 1 59
il est toujours à l'antenne je sais
qu'il a avec tf1 laurence boccolini en à
56 alors pourquoi une question d'âge
alors que eux sont encore à l'antenne
donc ça fait un petit peu ça vous pensez
que c'est un brave de caractère le
problème vient d'autre part en tout cas
donc le caractère je pense
qu'aujourd'hui fait plus qu'il est très
compliqué à travailler au quotidien
c'est une émission marche à plus fort
ses émissions de faillite serait
forcément ça marche plus mais c'est trop
facile de dire qu'il a mauvais caractère
parce que qu'ils soient sur tf1 ou tf6
et la même chaîne c'est pareil si
vraiment il était ingérable serait ni
sur tf1 mais sur tf6 vous devez non
monsieur je souffre et une question
pourrait être effectivement une marche
moins bien parce qu'il est plus âgé il a
vieilli parce que c'est d'être un peu
ringard maintenant j'en sais rien
bayonetta qui se passe ils auraient dû
peut-être arrêté au moment où il était
encore je connais un peu d'effort
bernard aussi
défunte et fx après c était un et des
vins non je voulais simplement dire
qu'il faut pas oublier tout de même que
dechavanne a ouvert la voie à un nouveau
style d'animation c'est moi à l'époque
quand je suis arrivé à tf1 187 et lui il
était déjà une star il faisait encore
mieux c'était un couple encore et encore
mais l'après midi il a eu une façon de
2,2 de parler d'interviewer des très
décontracté et c'est hélas ouvert la
voie de très nombreux animateurs et un
domaine et je pense qu'il a un frère et
beaucoup d'allant très créatif dont
cyril dans moi dans mon courant pour
coco c'est le marais et pourtant ça veut
rien dire d'être un jab
regardez vous vous pétez un peu pendant
les pubs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
désagrège je me bats pour avoir un
niveau médias à peu près potable avec
d'autres personnes sérieuses dont kevin
vatant nicolas pernikoff et ben voilà au
régime c'est jeannot caso oui oui il ya
peut-être aussi une raison évidemment
ingérable on l'entend beaucoup je le
connais pas personnellement mais c'est
un programme qui correspond aussi à tfx
donc c'est peut-être aussi cette raison
non mais de shane et le chaman adore les
animaux il fait beaucoup
les refuges et processus